their representatives of the media
welcome to the press conference of prime
minister Marin president of the
commission from The Lion prime minister
Carlos Deputy Prime Minister bush
we will start with brief remarks from
the speakers and then
move on to questions
prime minister Martin de floresios
thank you dear president of the European
commissioner Ursula the Estonian Swedish
colleagues prime minister colors and
Deputy Prime Minister Ebert Bush their
representatives of the media I'm happy
to host the high level speaker and all
of the participants today at this event
in haltia Finnish Nature Center
literally in the middle of woods
today's discussion focus on Wood
Construction and sustainability
the Finland forests are a source for
many benefits environmentally socially
and economically
we have a long tradition of building
with wood and now we see a growing
interest in using wood materials in
construction
this event brings together dozens of
scientists designers construction
experts and businesses in the Forester
sector to discuss how we can design and
build for a better future
when we aim for carbon neutrality we
must reduce emissions also from the
built environment
in the EU we have already taken many
steps in Energy Efficiency
next we need to take steps in material
efficiency
and here bio-based Solutions can really
make a difference
at the same time we are of course
focused must maintain a careful balance
between harvesting and Safeguard
biodiversity
first ecosystems also place a vital role
in our carbon neutrality goal
in our efforts it is important to also
bring in the creative potential of
architecture and design to come up with
you know innovative solutions
I want to thank the commission and you
personally Ursula for launching the new
European Bauhaus initiative which
highlights the importance of skills in
low carbon boot Construction
I'm happy that we are able to support
this with the Nordic Bauhaus initiative
I'm glad that now's finland's
participation with the development
online courses and digital learning
materials for Wood Construction
dear colleagues I want to thank you for
participating in this event today we
will now continue our discussion with
President Wonder Lion on other topical
issues on First and Forestry
these include the commission's recent
proposals which have raised a lot of
attention and also concerns in our
region where forests and Forestry are of
such great importance
we will of course
touch upon other key European issues
today as well including our unwavering
support for Ukraine and energy security
I will now give the floor to the
president of the commission the Ursula
at the floor is near yours thank you
very much yesana thank you very much for
bringing us here ever
indeed it's wonderful to be here in
halitzia a truly exceptional place and
even more stunning with the cold and
wintry atmosphere that we're
experiencing right now
and at the same same time seeing the
snow and feeling the cold
I cannot avoid thinking of our Ukrainian
friends
the Ukrainian people
because of Putin's barbaric terroristic
attack on the country's civil
infrastructure must face this oncoming
winter with no electricity and in many
places no running water
because of him
babies their parents and grandparents
are freezing in the dark
that I strongly condemn these barbaric
attacks they are war crimes
but I also know that our Ukrainian
friends will overcome this tragedy
because they are strong
and their cause is just
and we the European Union stand here by
them in these very difficult times as
long as it takes
we are working hard to hit Russia where
it hurts
to blunt even further its capacity to
wage war on Ukraine and I can announce
today that we are working full speed on
a ninth sanctions package
and I'm confident that we will very soon
approve a global price cap on Russian
oil with the G7 and other major Partners
we will not rest until Ukraine has
prevailed over Putin and his unlawful
and barbaric War
now let me come back to what brings us
here today and indeed halcya a wooden
Heaven by the lake and the view is
stunning
with most modern techniques
to me it perfectly captures the spirit
of your country but also of these
conference we have today so a place
where tradition and Innovation is in one
hand
the building sector we have been
discussing today we are discussing today
accounts for one third of the eu's
greenhouse gas emissions
and building can produce buildings can
produce an enormous amount of waste
globally so what we are discussing here
today and what we want our buildings and
cities that are instead of emitting
becoming carbon sinks and thus helping
us in the fight against climate change
with the new European Bauhaus we want to
address these topics and we want to
de-carbonize the building sector the
building stock we are looking for
nature-based Solutions like here in
halcio where there is obviously a plant
covered roof that soaks up carbon soaks
up sunlight sunlight and rain water
so I'm very happy to that today the
country is committed to contribute to a
new European Bauhaus Academy for
sustainable Construction
this Academy the new European Bauhaus
Academy will focus mainly on research
and Innovation and on Skilling the
necessary skills that we need for the
green transition mainly in the
construction sector
as a first step we will offer online
learning courses on bio-based materials
in construction and with Horizon Europe
we will call for bio-based material
projects worth 10 million euros in this
research and Innovation call
I'm very grateful for this excellent
conference because we know that forests
are our best allies to fight climate
change
we have to protect them but we also have
to work with them
and therefore all our efforts in
implementing the European green deals
are to find the right balance to strike
the right balance between the increased
sourcing of natural products for
construction we need them and the health
of our forests
forests are essential as I said in the
fight against climate change and
biodiversity loss at the same time our
forests have a huge economic value
and I'm very much looking forward to my
visit this afternoon to one of the
biggest Finnish Swedish Forest companies
this will be fascinating to see because
they are an excellent example
for the growing awareness in the
business sector
that nature restoration is not only
about sustainability
it is also a business strategy to
maintain the sources of their business
so our common aim should be exactly this
to find multiple wins for biodiversity
for our climate and for our economy
I know that from some member states this
is already a reality but others in the
European Union will have to go a way to
go in some we have a ambitious climate
goals we all agree on but now it's time
to show that we can really deliver
I want to make very clear that we are
strong supporter of the principle of
subsidiarity
so I want to make very clear it's the
member states it is the local
communities who are in the driving seats
for their plants how to approach the
topics to protect the forests and to
have economic activities in the forests
when it comes to the inflammation
implementation of all this it's your
plans
you own them and you are in the driving
seat we only support you as much as we
can this conference today showed an
impressive amount of innovative
solutions and back press best practices
so a Pioneer to move on many thanks for
having invited me
thank you thank you sorry yeah
I do it and then I got it all right
I'm I'm very happy to be here today
thank you for the invitation and thank
you for organizing this this event I
think it's it's very very timely
um that also thank you Ursula for this
new Bauhaus initiative as as we were
saying we need to see the forest behind
the trees then zoom out of the out of
the picture really what is at stake here
um
every Estonian feels very passionate
about the forests so Estonia as well as
Finland and Sweden are Forest rich
countries and forests have a special
role in our culture and in the hearts of
our people we expect a lot from our
forest beats in the role in absorbing
carbon or the role as a source of
livelihood and provider of the resources
finding a balance between those
sometimes conflicting roles of
preservation and news is challenging
increasing natural zinc and biodiversity
also are important goals in that regard
we should perhaps think about just
transition for the parts of Forestry
sector that will will be left Left
Behind
uh we're in Estonia and also in Finland
and Sweden have a long experience in
sustainable Forest management so it is
only natural that we should take the
leading role in transforming the sector
to be future proof
after all we want our forest to last so
we have to choose how we can better
value the wood from our forest and make
wooden products that also bind carbon be
it furniture or wooden houses or even
actually jewelry we should also make
preserving forests profitable for the
owner not just logging in this regard
the new European Bauhaus initiative is
specially important wood is a natural
fit in the Bauhaus initiative to deliver
sustainable construction this is why I'm
also proud that we are announcing today
a new platform between Estonia Finland
and Sweden to develop skills related to
the use of wood and provide
opportunities for our Societies or
scientists and companies to work
together
this platform will be also be part of
new European Powerhouse Academy that the
European commission just launched I'm
also very happy that Estonia will be
joining the Nordic Bauhaus family
um as Ursula mentioned we have a
barbaric war going on in Europe and what
we also see is that Russia is using
energy as a weapon in this in this war
so we also see that forests have a very
important role there renewable energy
getting rid of fossil fuels that will
make us more independent and more
sustainable thank you
and I'm very proud to be here together
with president vondelian and my Finnish
and Estonian colleagues in this
beautiful venue it's not every day that
you get the opportunity to have a press
conference with a backdrop of birch
trees but as a Countryside girl from
outside of uppsala I feel right at home
and thank you so much there urusilla for
taking this initiative and incorporating
the new Bauhaus skills program as as one
of the priorities and once again there's
Sana for for hosting this and and giving
this topic so much
um important time to be discussed today
we are gathered to discuss the great
possibilities that sustainable forestry
and Innovation can give us in order to
find solutions for the climate change
challenge as well as our future living
environment then pressing knowledge and
Ambitions found here today makes me
hopeful
regarding these challenges the green and
digital transition are opening up new
opportunities for people and the EU
economy having relevant skills empowers
people to successfully navigate label
Market Challenge and changes and to
fully engage in society and democracy
a Workforce with skills that are in
demand also contributes to sustainable
Innovation and improves companies
competitiveness
however
currently more than three quarters of
companies in the EU report difficulties
in finding workers with the necessary
skills
I'm therefore proud to announce that
Swedish research Council formas will
support activities within the Nordic
Bauhaus year of skills to develop how
building constructions architecture and
design can help in achieving carbon
neutral and inclusive ways of building
and living
among those activities there will be
developed opening e-learning as we heard
um Kaya talk about here earlier open
e-learning materials for skilled
building within the construction and
architecture sectors for the Nordic and
EU and EB Community during 2023 and
2024. there is a saying
um or a question are we out of the woods
yet as a way of asking are we out of of
the the danger and I would say that the
way moving forward and navigating past
the imminent dangers of climate change
is not going out of the woods but into
the woods thank you once again for
hosting this
thank you we have time for at least one
question so please
yeah my name is I am from The Finnish
Broadcasting Company and I guess my
question goes to president of the EU
commissioner lion
um Public public debate on the
commission's nature restoration plan has
been highly critical in Finland and I
guess the main concern is related to
costs
um do you think that the proposal is
fair to Finland in cost wise and um will
the commission make changes to the
proposal based on the feedback
so the proposal is right now in try log
so there we can support by moderation
but it's the Parliament and it's the
council that are finally negotiating the
nature restoration plan
um what is very important is we agree on
a common goal to fight climate change
the climate goals we have all agreed in
the European Union
and part of this is of course keeping
biodiversity and having healthy forests
and here is important that you with your
vast experience
we can learn from the experience how to
balance the economic use of the forest
and how to protect and restore the
forest where it's necessary so that this
learning experience goes all across the
European Union for that we need data
and we've seen that partially data are
available
but in the case of Finland for example
you're pretty good at data but you have
the data for 60 of the forest and for 40
not
so then we've done different modeling
and of course some of the modeling must
be the 40 where we have no data and we
have no idea in what state the forest is
um you can take the best case scenario a
middle case scenario and the worst case
scenario and only if you look at the
worst case scenario you come to the
figures that are being debated so it's
more up to us together now to provide
the missing data for the 40 look at the
state and then work together to improve
uh or restore or maintain the good
health of the forest very important
for all that is if action is needed
European funding because it's a European
approach so uh we have around about 14
billion for biodiversity every year
common European money and there are six
to eight billion
um could go to forests for example and I
think this is very important not only
for Finland but also for Sweden and
Estonia we share the common approach we
know how precious the forests are we
know how important they are for the
lives and livelihoods of people as an
economic foundation too so we share the
goal to protect them if necessary
restore or keep them healthy and for
that we need the common approach that I
was I was just describing also very
important and I want to re-emphasize
that
um to have a European approach we need
the 27 different member states to
develop their plans how they go forward
with the force it is your plans it's a
bit the logic of Next Generation EU it's
your plans you develop them you come
with uh your ideas the commission is
only commenting commenting so comparing
showing what others are doing best
practices but it's your friends that
feed into the common goal of having
reaching our targets to preserve this
planet
thank you unfortunately our time is up
thank you sorry
for me thank you all the press
conference has ended very good thank you
the lengthy response